recently a lot of people in the my hair
academia community
have been going pretty crazy over the
news that touhou animation is currently
working
on a new series in this universe the
info was casually released in licensed
global magazine
with the exact quote saying that they
have plans for a new animated series
retail campaigns and mobile games this
wording led people to theorize that a
vigilante spin-off anime is
finally on the cards given it already
has a pre-existing manga
that ties directly into the main
timeline especially for season five
however i just gotta say that it's
possible licensed global are just
referring to my hero season 5
and whoever wrote this they just used
words that happen to imply
a spin-off might be happening one way or
another we will be finding out next year
in 2021
but today i thought i'd give my take on
what i prefer to see
if this news about a new series is legit
i don't know if anyone at touhou watches
my videos
but i think i speak for a decent section
of the fans when i say that i would
prefer
a true or might prequel above almost
anything else
let's think about this for a second
there are some seriously interesting
mysteries about this character that are
yet to be explored
for example all might refer to his
master nana shimura
as you know he thought of her as his own
mother which
has a ton of implications what was his
real mother like did he even know her
i feel like if his real mom was in his
life he probably wouldn't say something
like this about nanashimura
unless of course his real mother hated
him but who could hate all might
i think it's possible that like many
protagonists his parents died when he
was young and he may have been raised
in less than ideal conditions if i'm
correct about that
then it might partially explain his
desire for there to be a pillar in
society that people can look up to
in hope we know that he was born
quirkless which was a
rare thing even back then meaning that
in the eyes of other children
he was likely a prime candidate for
bullying that's just the way kids are
like if you're different in a negative
way
they will most likely try and pick on
you in some way
perhaps he suffered abuse in a similar
way to deku although instead of going
home to a loving mother like income
midoriya
all might had no one to support him and
also no one to look up to
anyway i had a list of four additional
things that should be touched on if they
decide to do a prequel series
and let me know if i've missed anything
that you would like to see if this does
happen
to start with i think it would be a
great opportunity for us to learn about
the history of ua
for example who founded it and how it
rose to be the most respected hero
school in japan
the creation of ue would obviously be
before all might's time you know he's
not that old
but i think it's something that could
still be touched upon in any prequel
series
as pure speculation i would imagine that
ua was founded by a
former vigilante as we know that before
licensed pro heroes became a thing
random vigilantes would just suit up in
costumes and pretend to be heroes
this makes them the most experienced
when it comes to actually teaching kids
how to be pros furthermore we'd get to
see the other types of heroes that
attended ua at the same time as the
symbol of peace
you know perhaps maybe some that we have
encountered during our time in the
series
personally i would imagine that this
samurai hero who ranked number nine on
the charts
he's quite old so maybe he was even a
t-shirt at ua when all might was there
in the same way that gran torino was i
reckon they're roughly the same age
but yeah i think it would also be good
just to see all my's classmates and you
know where they are now are they
heroes in japan still or are they across
the world this would be a really
interesting thing to touch on
secondly a prequel is a great chance to
show off new and original quirks
possessed by all for one that we've
never seen before in the words of gran
torino
afo's abilities in kamino were
completely different from when they
faced him
six years earlier so could you imagine
how much more different they would be
during all might's young years when he
was in high school overhaul said that
all for one stole quirks to gain power
and a really effective way of doing that
is stealing the quirks of established
professional heroes
not only would the quirks themselves be
really great but obviously other heroes
would be afraid to
oppose all for one for fear of losing
their own powers
so yeah we would definitely need more
focus on all for one
because i mean when we look at the main
series being real
it's a story about deku and shigaraki
all my and afo were well past their
prime
you know as soon as we met them really
so it would be good to have a series
where we see
afo at his top and all might on his way
to the top
thirdly i want to know about any great
heroes during this era that maybe all
might
took inspiration from even if only a
little bit it goes without saying that
nana shimura and gran torino had
profound
impacts on him but what about the hero
known as brave
back in the cultural festival gentle
criminal mentioned how all might
crimson riot and brave were heroes that
left their shining mark on history
however unlike the rest brave is a
totally unknown entity we have no idea
what he or she might look like
but perhaps brave could have more
prominence in the prequel series
whether they be a retired hero or an
ex-vigilante
there's also actually a hero called mr
brave in the main story
who can shapeshift his hair into various
tools so perhaps he was inspired by the
real brave
in much the same way that red riot was
inspired by crimson riot
and deku is inspired by allmight but
yeah the point is
a new prequel series could offer more
insight into iconic japanese heroes that
maybe we just don't have time to learn
about in the main series
finally any almighty prequel would have
to show us how he motivated and changed
the part
of other people around him this is
something that deku has achieved
numerous times with the likes of
todoroki kota tenure bakugou ochako
and probably some other people that i
didn't mention in one way or another
each of the characters i mentioned
have either aspired to be better or have
had their view of the world changed
directly
because of deku's presence similarly a
young almighty would definitely have an
effect on the people around him
with his natural charisma his charm and
just his talent
so knight i said that both deku and all
might have the same fire and drive
inside them
so i'd love to see how all might went
around like winning the hearts and minds
of people
even as a young kid if this news about
touhou creating a new series is legit
then i i imagine how many series it
would be because
if it was only one season and it was
this all my prequel idea
then i think it should span from all my
younger days to his ua days
and then include the death of
nanashimura and flash forward to his
fight with all for one
that occurred six years before the main
series that would wrap up the timeline
very nicely and give us
pretty much everything we need to know
going into my here academia
also it's just nice to sometimes watch
things in chronological order
like star wars i guess you could say
regardless of whether it happens or not
i feel like all my time in america will
100 become its own movie one day
and i i have a few reasons for thinking
this but they're partially based on
comments from hirokoshi
that he wasn't really sure of a way to
top heroes rising because you know in
the first movie he had
all might and deku working together then
the second movie he has bakugo and deku
working together
so it's like what do you do for the next
one and in my opinion it'd just be good
to change
almost change the cast completely but
still have it with characters that we're
familiar with
so in all my prequel if they're gonna do
more movies i think it will have to come
eventually
anyway those are my thoughts on what i'd
like to see from an almighty prequel
and i hope this licensed global thing is
what we think it is
because i'd love to see any spin-off
series to be honest but you know you
know my preferred option but i would
love to see any spin-off
let me know what you guys think down
below would you rather have a vigilante
spin-off or an almighty spin-off or
something else
remember to subscribe if you want more
videos like this and until the next one
peace out
you